now even though the first day of school
is more than a month away hundreds of
military families ready for the new year
with some back to class Essentials
Victoria Saha takes us to the annual
back to school Brigade hosted by
operation Homefront
operation home front wants to make it as
easy as possible for our military
families and their kids to go back to
school they've already sacrificed so
much so they're able to get a free
backpack and school supplies to start
off with the new school year
for the 16th year military families in
Las Vegas don't have to worry about
paying for school supplies especially
right now during the rough time you know
everyone everything's uh really
expensive veteran Don real Mendoza has
three kids all going back to school so
his expenses for supplies are always
triple unless you think you're saving
right now um probably about
300 400 according to the National Retail
Federation for the last school year
families with Elementary to high school
students were expected to spend up to an
average of 864 dollars on back to school
items if I didn't have this it'll be a
lot of penny pinching
um so I'm glad to just be able to to uh
to be a recipient of this all right can
you tell me what's in your backpack
um I have a piggy bank a cup a Notebook
4 00 backpacks
packs that were donated by back to
school to school America with the help
of many organizations it helps ease the
struggle for our military families we
provide this relief to keep them strong
stable and secure which is a part of our
mission after the students have gotten
their backpacks they can go ahead and
sit down with Santa and take a picture
he says it's hot here it's hot here it's
110 but it was 60 degrees at the North
row operation home front oh
Victoria Saha eight news now now on a
national level operation home front is
expected to distribute up to 30 000
backpacks to military families this
summer